19 regular season games with New York and then
their first round playoff series against New
Jersey other one hit surgery in early June
Robbie fabry comes out from behind the net
Sav by sherkin working the buck below the goal
line it started in the first shift if the net
never came off the morning B again now leaving
it for paner here's with room tamy paner back
out to Fox and out the with a shot deflected
by crder off the goal [Music] [Applause] post
there's laier p a and cutting for the net pass
across and paner and chips it [Applause] line
just over a minute remaining on this power
play croch stopped twice cuso hangs on to
it bro zinski called yesterday by the Rangers
LA forier that's La forier backand shot stop
rebound of t coer comes away with the puck and
cck will flip it down into the ranger Zone the
wide rder plays it behind the net out in front
saved BYO on paner and Red Wings are back in
full strength got to be quicker there's back
pressure all over every team has back pressure
in the National Hockey League the Rangers
take a lot of pride in it you got to get
it on the on the at least in these situations
about to break it with a shot turn aside by
shurin go spar with a shot loose puck in front
to stking down Red Wings keep it alive go Spar
miss the net on that attempt back out it
comes for go save to sturing this seems
like a much different player from the last
couple of Seasons where maybe injuries were
playing a factor and maybe as confident up by fer
missed the net oh and that one an opportunity for
strong here Raymond blocked off by Miller
talk about the Red Wings offensively this
season they're fourth in the league
in goals four no lock in tonight and
they'll be adding Patrick Kane to the
near future here's paner with a shot he
scores RMI panan with his F goal of the season one
nothing [Applause] Rangers but this is not about
him shooting the puck here it's about the pass
that lafir makes I mean he he gets whoo to get
set on a potential shot turn over by the Red Wings
and then watch Laugh here here he's got of sells
shot and slides it over no chance for who so Jody
no not at all how about Keandre Miller you take a
look at the at 5G net tough power play for Detroit
losing battles on the walls entries not good and
giving up a couple of chances so far so let's see
if this latter half of the power play can and get
set up sty back out for cop out to the right
point for cider L cider with a shot score the
Red Wings tie it on the power play cider as the
Red Wings enter the puck will eventually get up
top to cider and watch what cider does I mean he
just gets to the middle of the ice recognizes that
there's some traffic in front cop gets there not
sure if he gets a redirect or not but the idea by
cider jod to get it to the net with some traffic
is a recipe for Success yeah smart play on the
wall too you pull out the defender and then you
get that passing Lane back to cider he really
took his time and that mobile defenseman you see
it in every team in the National Hockey you know
and often times in the power play you want to look
for the perfect play I I think that that can be
problematic for a lot of teams well it slows
things by Fab score so the Red Wings take the
lead with two goals in 23 seconds the Red Wings
get to work and you can just see right here along
the boards support strengthen numbers get a little
bit of help at the last minute fabry helps out and
eventually fabry gets the return feed from Buren
and he's able to put it home fabri a guy that has
scored in the past gets to a scoring area good
feed from berren and a little bit of traffic in
front of sh circuit Fab scoring his fifth goal in
nine games this season so just like that Red Wings
lead two1 turn around shot by pit stopped by whoo
big save by the Red Wings Gender there's no time
and space b and you're right any hesitation those
Lanes blose up quickly control shot blocked by
Ras out in front whoo [Music] [Applause] covers go
spare watched by benino on to the Stick of pan the
return for go spare across the break it without
a ATT the lurin coming across from left to right
and the Rangers clear the puck down ice just over
a minute remaining on the power play for Detroit B
took a hard hit there in the corner seems to be
okay but good adjustment there by Detroit gosis
bear wanted a little bit of a change ask her pan
to come over giving go and that opened up the scam
play now saan J coming in oneon-one G to spare
back the B J cross ice and a save by whoo on crder
Raymond comes away with the Pucket now a two-on
one back the other way the brink it with pad pass
across for parad and the pck bouncing Rangers
get to it Pon then keeps it alive for Detroit
but 96 and 92 points the last two years and now
off to a great start here comes wheeler Blake
wheeler moving in stopped by whoo Willer with it
again par the flex out and it's baren for the Red
Wings now now it's to Brink it back the other way
for Raymond Raymond with Comer cutting for the net
tries to get a two shot Love Save By sh sterin
what a save here by shurkin DeAndre Miller for
the Rangers into the Red Wing Zone tries to split
through cider comes away with the pp and taken
away by cder stopped by whoo here come the Rangers
cider is back Fox waiting for teammates Lo out
for Json dropping it off his in front through the
crease off the th of Tock and that a save made BYO
as the puck will flip back towards the goal under
11 minutes remaining here's krider rder cross eyes
pass off the Stick of zad now zad with itad back
out shot star DeAndre Miller ties the game at
two you talk about patience and skill here I
mean an attempt that doesn't go their way but
watch this move here and be able to hang on to
the puck wait patience find the play I mean the
opportunities aren't there on straight shots
so you got to try an East West plays the bad
finds Miller and a perfect finish for the ranger
defenseman there's sprong crosses off the stick
to valeno oh great look there byong penalty
expires here's laier just out of the box and
a two2 game thr check full off for in air saved
by whoo easy [Applause] score well the Rangers
come up with a huge kill good job by the Rangers
to get the kill and eventually get out of their
zone now we're five on five and initial shot
stopped by Willie hoo you can see the rebound
it just a real good job by VC to get a stick
on it I think it's good Jody it's below the
crossbar and what a what a what a goal for the
Rangers what a finish for VC how both down one
and then two it's almost like a trick goal
there for BC as he's right in front and how
about laugh you're out of the box he directed
traffic had that puck got it over to troch and
then he fell down in the middle of the ice and
this play is tremendous as you're right that's
at the crossbar or below and that's a good goal
but the hand eye coordination and the wherewithal
here that's a quick play in slow motion you
can see and appreciate it but wow Here We Go
Raven with the puck back out CER shot blocked
by good R time winding down and that will do
it the New York Rangers with two third
period goals and excellent goal tending